I know people are getting all upset
about World War I but I'll tell you
right now you will W until you're emoli
in your house by a Chinese nuke you will
never be asked to do anything you will
World War III will be the most
entertaining thing before you are emoli
in your house by a Chinese nuke you will
not have to do any you will be looking
at your treadmill on your couch when
you're vaporized no one will come to you
and ask you to do anything except maybe
you go to the call center we're still
open they'll call you and they'll tell
you they yeah but there's like a nuke
warning today we're still open and you
know what how beautiful it would be for
you to get nuked while you were calling
an elderly person with dementia trying
to get their credit card information as
you were calling an elderly person with
dementia trying to get their credit card
information it just the nuke sails and
it's just over and you just see the
beautiful glow outside the window of the
call center no one will ask you to suit
up and [__] get your fat ass in a Top
Gun plane you can't fit in and fly over
to China no one's going to ask you to do
that you so don't be
upset they'll either figure it out or
they won't we're very good at at coming
close to death in this country and not
fully going over it we're very good at
not fully going full Hell mode you know
but we'll see I don't know Israel maybe
reain it in a little bit Hamas released
the hostages maybe some progress there
we don't know but be rest assured
America's not going to really ask too
much of its citizens it knows
better it knows better the war is at
home the war in America will always be
at home and it's a war that you're lucky
to be part it's lucky you're lucky
because it's not the war that the people
in Gaza are going through where they're
being killed all the time this war is
like between college kids are
fighting people are
angry people are chanting in the street
but it's there's not that much of a it's
not like you're surrounded by mass
death from politics you're surrounded by
Death from other things but not not from
politics yet so this is just the war at
home the war at home will be like what
do I post well I just don't know I don't
know what to post my silence has been
noticed by some of the people on the
board godamn it that's the war at home
it's a it's a very first
world somewhat you
know kind of
emotional strategic War being fought by
upper middle class professionals that
are trying to dance around each other
that are
participating knowingly in this Kabuki
theater of making each other feel good
but you're not without water you're not
without electricity you're not like the
people in Israel without their children
right for the most part this just is an
exercise in the futility of
opinions that's what it is it's an
exercise in the futility of opinions
everybody's got to have one immediately
even though they're pretty worthless and
they certainly don't move the needle on
either side but you got to have one and
you sit there and you talk to your
husband Frank Frank what do you think
about this well the Middle East well the
well
Frank now listen I gotta post something
on Facebook about the
Jews what Frank what do I say well you
know the woman who works next to me in
the data collection agency is Jewish and
she's going going through everyone's
social media and if she doesn't see
something she likes she's saying we're
Nazis and I'm not a Nazi Frank so what
do I
say or it's people that are like you
know trying to figure out the the the
real cool you know detached thing to say
some brilliant treaties
on human's nature and deep oh it's deep
isn't it it's deep it's deeper than that
it's you don't even you take your [__]
out it's your [__] one because it's not
even about what you think it's about
it's so many layers deeper than that
it's deeper than those Hamas tunnels
baby it's so deep it's so deep it feels
so good it hurts but it's the only way
to get to pleasure is pain it hurts you
want to be tied up and vulnerable don't
you you want to be T I mean it's weird
and it's like you know but what it is is
the futility of it pants meaningless
people have no idea what they're talking
about they never do it's something that
we all have to do we all have to do it I
get paid to do it and hopefully some of
the things I say are at the very least
entertaining but it's the futility of op
it's people being like well and then the
letters oh the
letters signing the
letters Kate ched and Alec
Baldwin I want to sign a letter it's me
OJ Simpson Caitlyn Janet can I sign a
I'm gonna write a letter as soon as they
let me back on Instagram I'm writing a
letter and it's going to be all the
celebrities that nobody wants Kevin
spacy OJ Simpson Tim Dylan Tanya Harding
and we're gonna write a letter uh
demanding things that have nothing to do
with
this but it's all the letters
everybody's writing letters and here's
the letter we're signing the letter it
dare you it's signing the letter what is
the language of this letter going to be
well I don't know what are we suggesting
what are we insisting what are we going
to do who are we going to disenfranchise
let's fight let's fight about the
language of the letter the language of
the meaningless letter that we write and
send to President Biden who doesn't know
what letters are he doesn't know what
they are he's completely left the planet
but someone's going to go there's a
letter here there's a letter and you
need to read it
why because Aquafina signed it who what
how who what where
how the celebrities are writing letters
and going back and
forth we demand this and we demand that
fif I smell the blood of an Englishman
write the letter which letter have you
signed silly silly silly Society silly
culture it's what it is